and john fetterman has finally agreed to
debate his gop challenger and my next
guest dr mehmed oz it's going to happen
late next month just two weeks before
the election so there's a few caveats
though from uncle festerman he wants to
use live
real-time closed captioning monitors and
according to the oz team fetterman wants
to have two
practice sessions in studio ahead of
time
joining me now is the other participant
in that debate dr mcmahon u.s senate
candidate republican pennsylvania dr oz
we spoke to the fetterman campaign and
they denied
the practice sessions claim saying both
campaigns will be doing pre-debate
walk-throughs that are very standard
every political debate that's not a
practice debate or whatever the hell the
os team is spinning this as your
response
well all i know is john feder he's been
dodging all questions not just debate
questions but those from the press and
from boaters which is frankly insulting
in a democracy i think he's doing it to
avoid
this uh this radical left ideology that
he has and he doesn't want to defend it
but under a lot of pressure he has
agreed to the short debate as you point
out he does want closed captioning and
we were told
that he wanted a few rehearsals which i
get i'm a physician i understand how
hard it is to deal with a stroke and
with heart failure i'm fine with him
taking rehearsals i would like to have
extra time
in the debates we can ask more questions
as many have including the washington
post have said you have to have multiple
debates please have them early so that
voters who are getting absentee ballots
next week don't have to wait a month and
a half doctor are you going to be sorry
to interrupt are you going to agree are
you going to agree to these terms with
the closed captioning
situation that he's asked for i'm not
really getting that but
are you agreeing to that
i'm going to agree to allowing him to
have closed captioning and other
conditions that he may desire to make it
easier for him to debate i do believe he
owes pennsylvanians an honest assessment
of his health not double secret
probation tests that we find out about
on on television but really give voters
access to what's going on so that we can
have
all voters transparency into the process
listen i'm skeptical of what's going to
happen if he'll show up in this debate
that's scheduled two weeks before the
election he's often a no show he doesn't
show up for his lieutenant governor's
job but you've put you brought up
something that's really important you
know he the liberal press has been
hiding
this issue of his health they've been
hiding his radical positions this man
cares more about criminals than the
innocent you know not only is he hired
uh you know two murderers convicted
murderers serving life sentences that he
had uh released uh on his campaign but
he's backed a massive middle-class tax
hike but did not pay his own taxes 67
times so if this bothers you please go
to doctorhours.com and support me
because money is pouring into his
campaign to facilitate uh getting this
election into the democratic hands they
are literally manufacturing a candidate
he's not out on the campaign trail
talking to people answering questions so
folks don't know what he stands for you
can only find out by watching his
commercials i've been out there every
single day doing multiple interviews i
know and there and then they're trying
to censor
individuals who actually are taking his
clips and getting them out in a short
form way so you can post them on social
media and actually get people seeing him
so they're not allowing that either this
is this is like getting ccp like but i
want to talk about the voters that you
mentioned because fox spoke to a few
pennsylvania voters this week this is
what they had to say
i feel that the democrats have left us
down look around
watch the news
it's awful
i can't do it anymore i hope that the
republicans take back the house and
senate because we need to have a little
more stabilization
are you surprised that the polls still
show him leading
given what's happening the global
recession's upon us according to the
fedex ceo today
his lead is shrinking by the day i know
that i'll support police and i'll
address a shortage of police officers
that's why the federal order of police
have endorsed me unanimously when that
happens people who worry about crime
vote for me you know they don't want him
legalizing drugs having an open borders
offense it'll pours in uh to our state
we're number three for fentanyl
overdoses and creates huge areas of our
cities like kensington and philadelphia
that are uninhabitable with zombies
walking on needles sticking out of their
necks they don't want that so fetimen
loses those votes he believes he's above
the people and above the law and it's
catching up to him we will win in
pennsylvania
dr oz i think you should come into the
debate with your own hoodie and maybe a
stethoscope and then take it off and
then have your regular suit on this is
the whole hoodie thing it's just like
it's all a costume it's all wardrobe and
we appreciate you thank you so much for
coming on hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else